اهلا بكم تفقد وزير الدفاع للفرنسي قاعده
مادام الفرنسيه العسكريه في اقصى شمال
النيجر قربه الحدود مع ليبيا والمقرر
افتتاحها الربيع القادم بهدف مواجهه
الجماعات المتشدده في شمال افريقيا كما
تقول باريس نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقشه في
محورين
ماذا يعني وجود قاعده عسكريه غربيه على
مرمى حجر من ليبيا
هل هناك اهداف اخرى غير معلنه من الوجود
الفرنسي العسكري في المنطقه
اذا تفقد وزير الدفاع الفرنسي
قاعده مدام الفرنسيه العسكريه الجاري
تشييدها في اقصى شمال النيجر قرب الحدود
مع ليبيا التي من المفترض ان تكون جاهزه
للعمل الربيع القادم وسمع لشرح حول دورها
المتوقع في مواجهه الجماعات المتشدده في
شمال افريقيا قرب هذه القاعده من ليبيا
واطماع فرنسا القديمه في المنطقه يثيران
العديد من التساؤلات عن الغرض منها
علمتني طائره نقل عسكريه وصل وزير الدفاع
الفرنسي الى شمال النيجر من العاصمه
التشاديه حيث امضى ليله راس السنه مع
جنوده هناك وصل الوزير الفرنسي الى قاعده
عسكريه فرنسيه قيد الانشاء في مدام اقصى
شمال النيجر الواقعه على ابواب ليبيا
واثرت الزياره الكثير من الاسئله حول
الاستعدادات التي تقوم بها فرنسا لمواجهه
الجماعات المتجدده في ليبيا ومالي والنيجر
وتشاد والمناطق المجاوره لها واكد الوزير
ان بدايه العام 2015 ستظهر التصميم على
مواجهه من وصفهم بالارهابيين الذين يريدون
تحويل طريق القوافل القديمه الى طريق
للعنف والتهريب
ومن المتوقع ان تشكل القاعده العسكريه
التي تقع في الصحراء على بعد نحو 100 كم
جنوب الحدود الليبيه مركزا متقدما
للعمليات التي تشنها فرنسا في مواجهه
تنظيم القاعده في بلاد المغرب الاسلامي
وحركه التوحيد والجهاد في غرب افريقيا
وانصار الدين
وقد حذرت فرنسا اكثر من مره من توغل تنظيم
القاعده في بلاد المغرب والتنظيمات الاخرى
واستغلالها للمناطق الاستراتيجيه بالقرب
من قلعه مدام القديمه واتخاذها طريقا
لعبور الجهاديين ومهربي الاسلحه انطلاقا
من ليبيا باتجاه شمال النيجر ومالي
وتنشر فرنسا منذ اغسطس من العام الماضي
3000 رجل في منطقه الساحل والصحراء في
اطار عمليه برخان الهادفه للتصدي للجماعات
الجهاديه عبر الحدود وتشارك في هذه
العمليه خمس دول هي موريتانيا ومالي
والنيجر وتشاد وبوركينا فاسو
ويتوجس الفرنسيون خاصه والاوروبيون عامه
من انتجر الاحداث السياسيه والامنيه التي
تتصاعد في ليبيا الكثير من المشاكل
المباشره للقاره الاوروبيه كما يخشى ان
تتمدد التنظيمات الاسلاميه والجهاديه في
ليبيا والدول المجاوره لتصبح تهديدا حقيقا
في قلب البحر المتوسط لذا يقولون انهم
يفضلون مواجهه المشكله من المنبع
حلقتنا نناقشه مع ضيوفنا من بريزه عبد
القادر عبد الرحيم الباحث في معهد
العلاقات الدوليه ومن طرابلس صلاح الشلوي
الباحث في الشان الليبي ومن نواكشه محمد
محمود ابو المعالي الخبير في شؤون
الجماعات الاسلاميه مرحبا بكم جميعا لفتني
عنوان لا يخلو من دلاله في الحقيقه في احد
المواقع الاخباريه اسمه تحديدا
نيجر اكسبريس يقول واخيرا حصلت فرنسا على
قاعدتها في النيجر السيد عبد القادر ما
الذي تعنيه واخيرا هذه هل هذه القاعده
كانت حلما فرنسيا قديما لما كل هذه اللهفه
والحماسه للحصول على موطئ قدم ثابت في
النيجر
تاريخ الاستعماري لفرنسا ما يقلقنا حاليا
في السياسه التي تقوم بها فرنسا منذ سنوات
وهناك عوده لفرنسا تتمثل في حمايه افريقيا
في حين انه في عهد حكمه اشتراك وبعد قبل
قبل ذلك
مع افريقيا حاليا لدينا شعور بان هناك
تراجع واننا بشكل تدريجي نقوم بسياسه
استعماريه جديده حيث اننا نخوض حربا بتعله
اننا نقول باننا نجلب الديمقراطيه في حين
نرى ان الامر لا تجري على ذلك النحو
وبالرغم من ذلك نعاند ذلك ان هدف الحرب
ليس كما هو معلن وليس واضحا نرى بان الحرب
التي اطلقت في ليبيا حاليا تمثل كارثه
كارثه للمنطقه برمتها ولا يقتصر الامر فقط
على النيجر وانما بالنسبه
ومصر والجزائر التي هذه الدول التي تشعر
بالقلق حيال هذا الوضع في حين ان هذه
الحرب ذاتا الى فوضى اكبر من الفوضى التي
كانت موجوده تحت ديكتاتوريه القذافي اذا
السؤال الذي يطرح نفسه هو حاليا وهو اننا
لا نفهم لماذا فرنسا تعاند في اقتراف نفسي
الاخطاء حاليا نجد انفسنا في وضع يجعل
بانما نراه حاليا هو
نتيجه مباشره لحروب قامت من سنوات نتحدث
حاليا عن ليبيا حاليا لكن ايضا يمكن ان
اتحدث عن العراق وتاثيراته على سوريا وعلى
تركيا وغيرها
الامثله كثيره من اجل ان نبرهن على ان كل
هذه الامور
وتدخلات لا تنجح وانها تمثل السياسه
الجيده وان التقدم مواد الديمقراطيه هي
استنبات يقوم على تطور وليس على الثوره
ساعود اليك حتى اشرك ضيفين الاخرين سيدي
ابو المعالي من عمليه سروال الى عمليه
برخان الان معناها على اساس قيام هذه
القاعده الجديده وهذا التمدد الفرنسيه
العسكري في المنطقه كيف يمكن فهم
الاستراتيجيه
الفرنسيه في ظل كل المتغيرات الحاصله هناك
طيب شكرا جزيلا على الاستضافه الوضع ان
فرنسا منذ ايام الرئيس ساركوزي بدات تحاول
اعاده الهيمنه على المنطقه او تحويل
مصالحها او تحالفاتها الى هيمنه واقعيه في
المنطقه فرنسا تاريخيا كانت منطقه ساخن
ساحلي وشمالي افريقيا تخضع لها باستثناء
ليبيا بعد بدء عمليه
2013 وهي عمليه فرنسيه صرفه تمدون اشراك
اي حلفاء او اشراك المجتمع الدولي اليوم
العين الفرنسيه على ليبيا وعلى الجنوب
الليبي خصوصا الاعتبارات عديده اولا
الجنوب الليبي يشكلها نافذه تهديدا على
المصالح الفرنسيه في شمال النيجر
حيث منهجم اليورانيوم التي توفر ثلاثه
ثلاثه ارباعيه حاجه فرنسا من اليورانيوم
ايضا المصالح التقليديه ادي فرنسا في هذه
المنطقه قاعده ماداما هي قائده تقليديه
للاستمرار الفرنسي اسست
1930 اليوم تريد فرنسا بواسطتها ان تبسطها
واختارت منطقه الجنوب الليبي كمدخل نظرا
لاعتبار التداخل الديموغرافي والتداخل
الجغرافي بين سكان الشمال مالي وشمال
النيجر مع منطقه جنوب ليبيا وشمال معروفه
انها مناطق تعودت النهوض الفرنسيه
وتعودت الحضور الفرنسيه فيه الحجه اليوم
هي محاربه المجموعات التي توصف بالارهابيه
لكن الواقع ان الغايه القصوى هي محاوله
بسط سيطره عسكريه واقصاء اي تحالف او
شراكه دوليه في المنطقه هذا ما تسعى اليه
فرنسا عينها ايضا على ضفه البحر الابيض
المتوسط لان تعتقد ان وجود تهديد للمصالح
الفرنسيه والمصالح الغربيه بشكل عام في
ليبيا انما هو جديد على حدود القاره
العجوز وبالتالي تسعى لاحتوائه لكن
الحقيقه فرنسا تريد ان تكون سيده المنطقه
برمتها كان سيدتها ايام الاستعمار غابت
عنها ليبيا اليوم تحاول ان تستعد هذه
السياده وان يتمدد
ليبيا مستغله الوضع الهشه والصراع الليبيه
الداخلي واضح سي ملاحظه مركزيه لا بد من
التوقف عندها يعني في الاحداثيات احداثيات
الجغرافيه السياسيه لوجود هذه القاعده وقع
انشائها على تخوم منطقه الجنوب الليبي هل
ترى السيد صلاح ان هذه مصادفه ام كما بدا
يقول البعض يعني من خلال اللغط الذي اثرته
هذه الخطوه انها عمليه تسخين وربما للتحرش
او حتى للتدخل المباشر في منطقه الجنوب
الليبي
مساء الخير مساء النور اتصورا فرنسا كما
ذكر الاخوين العزيزين من نواكشوط
ان فرنسا لها وجود قديم في في القاره
الافريقيه خاصه في جنوبها وغرب القاره
حضور واسع والدول هي ربما الطوق بتاع
الدول فرانكفونيه
فوجودها اليوم في الجنوب هو بسبب ان هناك
جيل جديد من الاستراتيجيين الفرنسيين ممن
قراوا لم يعاصروا
فتره الاحتلال المباشر للجزائر وغيره هذا
الجيل من الاستراتيجين درسوا التاريخ
ولديهم في كتاباتهم وفي تناولهم لتاريخ
الوجود الفرنسي في القاره لديهم كان نوع
من التخطئه او الندامه على خروج فرنسا من
المنطقه كتاباتهم لا تدل على انهم كانوا
راضيين على انسحاب فرنسا من الجزائر وكان
خطا استراتيجي وقعت في فرنسا ما كان لها
ان تقوم به وهؤلاء طبعا هذا الجيل بدا
يظهر يعني تنضج رؤى هذه بتجيج الروح
القوميه او اليمينيه ان صح التعبير وهم
طبعا غالبهم او كلهم يمينيين طبعا
بداوا يبرزوا على السطح بشكل واضح في
المؤسسات الدوله في المؤسس العسكريه وفي
الخارجيه ايضا في عصر تقريبا رئيس تركيزي
يعني بشكل واضح وصارخ يعني حتى شفنا
الاحداث وسرعه تدخل فرنسا في المنطقه كانت
بسبب الاستشارات التي يقدمها هذا الجيل
طيب
هذه النظره التاريخيه الان الان وجود هذه
القاعده على مرمى حجر كما يقول الكثيرون
من الحدود الليبيه ما الذي يعني
الذي يعنيها ان هذه القاعده ليست كما تدعي
فرنسا لمواجهه الارهاب
لو كل منطقه فيها ارهاب عملوا فيها قاعده
معناها العالم كلها حيبقى قواعد فرنسيه
هذه هذا التواجد هو
لتعزيز مخطط في السيطره والهيمنه على
الجنوب الليبي وعلى موارد طبعا هذا بدا من
89 في لبان الحرب شديده الليبيه واقتطاع
جزء من الاراضي الليبيه لصالح تشاد في
صح التعبير مناجم او الجبال الغنيه
باليورينيوم وهذه طبعا كما ذكر احد الاخوه
انها مصدر ثلثي
الطاقه تبحث عنها فرنسا للقرن الجديد
فطبعا هذا طبعا واحد من الدوافع الرئيسيه
اضافه ان فرنسا ترى ان جنوب الليبي جزء من
المناطق التي ينبغي ان تتبع لها
وفي نظرتها لهذا
كيف تبدو قدره فرنسا يعني بالتعاون مع
حلفائها المحليين على الاقتراب اكثر او
توسيع نفوذها العسكري اكثر في اتجاه
الجنوب الليبي مع ملاحظه هامه وهو غياب اي
اسناد او دعم من دوله كبرى في المنطقه هي
الجزائر التي
تبدو رافضه تماما لاي تدخل وتخير الحل
السياسي والحل السلمي
صحيحه وهذه نقطه مهمه ففرنسا لا يمكنها ان
تتحرك عسكريا لوحدها في ليبيا اذا ارادت
ذلك ثانيا لقد اوضحتم كذلك امر في غايه
الاهميه وهو دوره الجزائر
وجسائر بحكم دستورها لا يمكنها ان تتدخل
خارج حدودها هذا ليس منصوصا عليه في
الدستور فقط ولكنها قناع راسخ لدى القاده
الجزائريين حيث انهم يحترمون سياده الدول
فرنسا تاسست بالاحرى الجزائر تاس على هذا
النحو ولا تود ان تغير نفسها واخيرا
فالجزائر حضرت ساكوزي وقالت له احذر احذر
اذا حاولت ان تطيح بنظام القذافي فان
تداعيات لا يمكن حسابها وستكون وخيمه
بالنسبه لكم الدول الاوروبيين الفرنسيين
ولكن ايضا بالنسبه لنا نحن لنا نحن في هذه
المنطقه وهذا هو ما حدث فعلا ذلك ان الحرب
في ماليه هي النتيجه المباشره
الاستقرار والفوضى الموجوده حاليا في
ليبيا اذا مجددا عندما نقوم بخوض حروب حتى
ولو كان لغايه سليمه فيجب ان يكون ذلك
لهدف سياسي محدد وبان بما ان هذا الهدف لم
يكن محددا منذ البدايه بالرغم من الحديث
عن قضايا الاخلاقيه والديمقراطيه فنحن
حاليا نجده انفسنا في مازق صحيح يجب ان
نؤكد على انهم نظر هذه فان فرنسا بحاجه
الا ان موقع نفسها من الناحيه الداخليه
وان تحدد وجودها التاريخ في هذه المنطقه
بمعنى القذافي لم يعد موجودا على اعتبار
القذافي كان يمثل عائقا لحضورها في هذه
المنطقه اشكرك سنعود الى النقاش ولكن بعد
فاصل قصير ابقوا معنا
اهلا بكم من جديد في هذه الحلقه التي
نناقش فيها الافتتاح القريب لقاعده
الفرنسيه في شمال النيجر سيد ابو المعالي
كيف كيف تقدر رده فعل الجماعات المسلحه
على هذه الخطوه الفرنسيه
هذه الجماعات في الاصل سياسه معروفه وهي
سياسه استدراج الخصم الى الارض التي
يحددونها هم وبالتالي لمحاوله محاربتهم
مباشره بدلا من محاربه ما يسمونهم عملائه
في المنطقه اذا بكل تاكيد الجماعات
المسلحه في المنطقه كانت تترصد هذه
القاعده وكانت تتوقعها وتحضر لها اعتقد ان
وجودا فرنسيا عسكريا مباشرا انما هو تحريض
انما هو محاوله لتوفير رافد ايضا لهذه
الجماعات لان يعني بصيغه من الصيغ عوده
الاستعمار الفرنسي من جديد المنطقه
ومحاوله توسع هذا الاستعمار وبالتالي
مخاطبه الوجدان الشعبي والوجدان التحرري
والوجدان الديني لدى المجتمعات المقيمه في
المنطقه ضد الوجود الفرنسي وبالتالي تاهيل
هذه المجتمعات الى ان تكون حاضنه اكثر مما
هي عليه لهذه الجماعات وان تكون دائما
لها هذه الجماعات ايضا جاء الفرنسيون بحجه
طردها من شمال مالي والقضاء عليها لكنهم
في النهايه
اكتفوا بالسيطره على كبريات المدن بينما
بقيت هي تحاول او تتمركزوا في الصحراء وفي
الجبال وفي غيرها اليوم تحاول قطع الطرق
الامداد او التواصل مع الجنوبي والشرق
الليبي وهو امر ولن في غايه صعوبته لم يكن
مستحيلا لانه من المعروف ان الطرق التهريب
التي خبرها المهربون على مدى العقود
الماضيه كثيره ومشتته وممتده على الاف
الكيلومترات سواء في المثلث الحدودي بين
ليبيا والجزائر والنيجر
في شمال يمر الامر عبر ولايه تمنراست جانت
تواوية الزواتين الى صحراء في النيجر والى
جبال الاضربيس مرورا بجبال وصولا الى
جبالغاز اذا هي منطقه شاسعه كبيره جدا
خبرها خبرتها هذه الجماعات
اخذت منها مراكز لها ومعسكرات وجدت مددا
لها في جنوبي وفي شرق الليبي وبالتالي
انما ستشكل هذه القاعده عمليه تشويش فعلا
او محاوله قطع الطريق لكنها ايضا ستشكل
مطلبا لهذه الجماعات يعني لانها استدراج
للعدو الى ارضهم ايضا ستشكل كما اسلفت
حافزا لهم لتجنيد الشباب ولتجنيد القواعد
الشعبيه الداعم له ايضا هي برهان ساطع على
ان الاطماع الفرنسيه انما هي في خيارات
الارض وليست لحمايه السكاني ولا البلدان
لانها انما عسكرت لتحميه مناجم اليورانيوم
وتحميه منجم الذهب الحديث لاكتشافي في
المنطقه قرب القاعده العسكريه ايضا لتحميه
مصالحها في تشاد قريبه وغيرها ستواجه ايضا
فرنسا لتاكيد الرفض الجزائريه للتدخل
الاجنبيه في المنطقه وحساسيه الجزائر
اتجاه الوجود الفرنسي في المنطقه والجزائر
اشكرك لا يمكن تجاوزها في عمل كهذا ايضا
ستواجه رفض المجتمع الليبي بشكل عام وهو
المنطقه الجنوبيه من منطقه قبائل بامتياز
المنطقه رافضه للاجنبيه ايا كان حتى ولو
كان قبيله جارا فكيف باوروبيا
صلاح ما حقيقه ان تكون الجماعات المتشدده
قد تاثرت فعلا يعني بهذا التواجد العسكري
الفرنسي المكثف وهو ما جعل البعض منها كما
تقول فرنسا نفسها يجد ملاثا امنا هكذا
تقول في الجنوب الليبي
نحن اذا صدقنا موضوع الجامعات الاسلاميه
فما ان هذا بالضروره صدقنا المزاعم
الفرنسيه لتغطيه اطمحها الاستماريه في
المنطقه يعني لا اظن ان مثلا الحكومه
الجزائريه من اكثر الحكومات خبره في موضوع
الجامعات الاسلاميه المسلحه في المنطقه هي
ترفض الاطماع الاستعماريه وتعتبر
مزاما فرنسا هي التغطيه لاطماء استعماريه
في المنطقه حتى الرئيس التشادي عندما زار
عندما زار الجزائر
وبينوا له الجزائريين طبيعه حقيقه الاطماع
الفرنسيه اصدر بيان وانهم مع الحل السلمي
والسياسي في ليبيا واستبعد موضوع التدخل
الخارجي كما بعكس محاوله فرنسا ان تقحم
الدول الخمس في هذا الموضوع فرنسا تتحدث
على على ارهاب في الجنوب العالم كله يتكلم
على ان صح التعبير على ارهاب في المنطقه
الشرقيه من ليبيا الاعلام الفرنسي والسحف
الفرنسيه لا تتكلم لا تعتبر ليبيا شيء سوى
ما هو يحدث في الجنوب متواحمه ومحاول ان
تصنع صوره معينه لتبرر التواجد الفرنسي في
الجنوب الليبي فرنسا تتكلم على على جزء من
العالم وتصطنع تحاول ان تصنع صوره في ذهن
الاعلام وفي دهن السياسيين الغربيين هي مش
موجوده على ارض الواقع والجزائريين هم
اكثر الناس ادراكا عندما يتم مواجهه
لفرنسيين والاطماع الفرنسيه سيواجهها
الشعب الجزائري والشعب الليبي والشعب
التشادي هؤلاء اما قصه في جماعات اسلاميه
تريد ان تقاوم فرنسا فهم هذا ما تحاول
فرنسا ان تسوقه للراي العام بحيث ان هي
يبرر ايجاد قواعد ايجاد قواعد ليس لمقاومه
ارهاب نحن شفنا انسحبت كل القواعد التي
وضعوها في افغانستان في الاسبوع الماضي كم
ستستغرق فرنسا من وقت كي تكرر نفس الاخطاء
التي ارتكبتها في الجزائر حتى تخرج بعد
ذلك في منتصف ربما القرن الحالي هذا
بهزيمه اخرى مثل التي خرجت بها في من
القرن الشعوب اصبحت مدركه وواعيه لهذه
التهديدات وهذه المخاطر فليبحث لهم عن
مكان اخر يمارس فيه مغامراتهم ويمارس فيهم
نظرياتهم القاصره التي لا تحسن قراءه
قانون التاريخ سعيد عبد القادر هل انت
متفق مع ان فرنسا هي تحاول فقط التسويق
لنظريه مقاومه الارهاب بينما الحقيقه ان
هذه المنطقه تاريخيا هي منطقه نفوذ فرنسيه
وفرنسا تريد الحفاظ على مصالح الاقتصاديه
كما كان يقول السيد ابو المعالي منذ قليل
هناك مناجم ايرانيوم هناك مناجم ذهب
والمساله ايضا لها طابع ووجه اقتصادي
بالاساس
بالتاكيد يجب ان اكون ساذجين فكافه الدول
تودوا بشكل شرعي ان تحمي مصالحها وتحافظ
عليها لكن فرنسا هشه في 75% من طاقتها
المستهلكه في البلاد هذه الطاقه النوويه
ولهذا السبب فان اليورانيوم الموجود في
النيجر يمثل
قضيه حيويه بنسبه الاقتصاد الفرنسي لا
يمكننا ان نتصور ان تكون فرنسا غير قادره
اقتصاديا ولهذا السبب نرى تدخلها فرنسا
ثانيا نشاهد ايضا بعدا استراتيجيا
يتمثل في في انه
بالاخص ما يتعلق بظهور تنظيم الدوله في
الشرق الاوسط تنظيم الدوله ما هي طبيبه
دوله هي نتيجه
لتدخل الغربي في الشرق الاوسط حيث ان
الغرب لم يتصرف من ناحيه السياسيه في وقت
مناسب ادى الى ظهور مثل هذه التنظيمات اذا
اذا تدخلت فرنسا في ليبيا عسكريا فيجب
لا تقوم بذلك في 2001 من خلالها الجو
وانما تتدخل من الناحيه بريه وفي هذه
الحاله الراي العام الفرنسي لن يقبل ذلك
ان تداعيات ونتائج مثل هذه التدخلات ليست
ذاتها عرفنا ذلك منذ الحرب الاولى الخليج
حيث ان الغرب كان يقول بحرب لا متفيها
وذلك امر لا يقبل لا يقبله الراي العام
الغربي حيث لا يقبله يدخل تؤدي الى مقتل
جنوده ذلك سيكون مثل وضعا صعبا بالنسبه
لحكومه هولندا التي تعانق اقتصاديه كذلك
من ناحيه سياسيه الوقت ربما لا يسمح لنا
بالاطاله اكثر فقط بقي سؤال سؤال قصير
للاستاذه ابو المعالي باختصار يعني في
دقيقه كيف تنظر الى مستقبل الصراع في هذه
المنطقه هل يمكن ان نرسم صوره نسبيه
المفصله على اساس كل هذه المتغيرات
الحاصله
الواقع ان هذه المتغيرات التي تحاول فرسان
تفرضها بقاعده عسكريه وبحضور عسكريه
تواكبها ايضا تطورات على مستوى الجماعات
الاسلاميه المسلحه هناك بعد حرب بدر حرب
الفرنسيه ولد تنظيم كبير هو جماعه
المرابطون اتحاد جماعتي توحيد والجهاد
والملثمون ظهرت تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه في
الجزائر وفي دارنا وفي غيرها اذن كل
الاطراف مقبله على تطورات وعلى مزيد من
التوتر حسب تصوري ايضا الطبيعه
الاستعماريه للقوى الفرنسيه ستجعل هذه
المنطقه تندفع نحو مزيد من الغليان نحو
مزيد من الرفض الاجنبي وبالتالي
ليست طبعا بالانظمه الحاكمه
انما سيكون مزيدا من التوتر والتصعيد
واللجوء الى مزيد من جماعه العنف وحمل
السلاح اشكرك سيد محمد محمود
الشلوي الباحث في الشان الليبي من طرابلس
ومن باريس عبد القادر عبد الرحيم الباحث
في معهد العلاقات الدوليه بهذا تنتهي هذه
الحلقه من برنامج مواقع الخبر نلتقي باذن
الله في قراءه جديده في مواقع خبر جديد